投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,現在是臺北時間2026年10月5號禮拜一,早上8點30分,大家早上好,我是林浩。
每天早上開盤前半小時,
我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經新聞時事變化,
兜兜轉轉來到慕尼黑過啤酒節,
還有一點忙,
但醉翁之意不在酒,
股民之意在開盤,
帶著一點醉意,
來等開盤也是非常有趣。
今天同樣跟投資朋友來追蹤
上禮拜非農就業數據爆冷之後
難道現在的升息預期就已經完全消失了嗎
過往種種殖利率預期的升高
現在可以靠一次的非農降溫來瓦解嗎
今天來跟投資朋友多做些觀察
畢竟上禮拜九月份
非農數據其實非常差勁
結果導致的結果居然是禮拜五
美國股市全面收高
這一次納指盤中是一度創下了歷史新高價
中場是上漲1.19%
來到27190點
那這一份落於預期的就業數據
我們待會會從不同層面來做拆解
因為它背後包括國債的問題
法債歐債的壓力
都可能是導致美國國債壓力
稍微降溫的原因
而並不是單純來自於非農就業數據
可是往好處想
不只是納指的走高
這一次就連廢辦的部分
AI最大巨頭揮打
在禮拜五盤中創下歷史新高價了
所以如果連揮達上方也是萬里無雲
這一次我們知道超維還有資安族群
也同步的強勢走深
都把納斯達克指數和肺瓣持續的往上推
這就值得觀察了
因為從技術角度來看
的確上方已經接近沒有任何的賣壓了
如果從美債長天期殖利率來看
現在是20多年來的高點
30年起一度來到5.69%
可是肺瓣還在飆
納指還在飆
如果細看納斯達克100指數
底下Move指數是債券的恐慌指數
債券這麼恐慌
但是似乎對於股票市場毫無影響
納指今年上漲幅度還是高達22%
那標普距離歷史新高價
現在也不到1%了
撐住市場核心的很明顯就是AI和科技巨頭
現在微軟、虧達、蘋果
在過去三個月
兩大指數是作為最重要的上漲貢獻者
你看蘋果
即便大家覺得對於iPhone 2
還是沒有那麼樂觀的銷售預期
現在剛開始開賣
可是還是給它相對高的評價
市場上之所以暫時忽略高利率
其實是因為獲利的預期
真的太強了
如果我們把科技業在第三季的每股盈餘
來做獲利的整體預估
大概是暴增65%
整個標普白指數
本來也沒有表現多亮麗
瞬間到今年第三季
已經成長到24%了
那它會導致一個很直觀的效果
就是本益比仍然以非常驚人的速度
快速的下行
所以現在科技巨頭
面對高利率的條件
跟2023年我們當然知道不一樣
那個時候利率才多高
可是現在的利率
10年期之利率
5%都還是能夠扛得住
原因就來自於
不是說估值沒有做回調
它已經很低了
低到人家覺得好像該買一點了
即便高值利率仍然存在
我們舉例來說
所以像高利率已經讓標普白指數的本益比
5月份大概是21倍
現在標普納指基本上都在創高
那Fibon也幾乎要做回升了
但是現在只剩下19倍左右
所以科技股獲利成長暫時把壓力給蓋住了
這個是目前最根本的主因
也就是獲利成長的速度
比美債利率成長速度所造成的資金沉壓的速度
還要來得更為快速
所以硬要講
如果我們把今年3月4月的伊朗戰事
當時的前瞻本一筆
拿來跟現在來做比較
現在即便我們知道
納指 費半 標普 臺股
都比今年3月4月還要來得高
可是現在的基期
比美伊戰事還要來得低
如果你看的是本一筆
看的是股價跟獲利的關係
而不是單論股價的話
這個就是非常有趣的一個跡象了
那再來一個好處就是
往7月份來看
其實科技股的籌碼
算是洗的比較乾淨一點了
因為我們知道這兩週
應該講說這兩個月
市場上其實就是一直在盤整區間
那很多沒有耐心的人
已經慢慢的離開
納斯達克指數
現在又開始重返新高以後
現在隨著半導體也開始做突破
現在有三大指數
有兩大指數
上方是萬里無雲
那費半呢
費半我們當然很清楚知道
好像上一輪在7月份的去槓桿之後
壓力非常大
可是現在也差不多
差不多已經接近到歷史新高的區域了
那有沒有可能隨時爆發新一輪的嘎空行情呢
尤其現在在最新的記憶體研究當中
供需吃緊
看起來也沒有任何提前的跡象
至少是延到2028年了
美光甚至預估2027到2028的供需狀況
甚至比26年來的更為緊張
那輝達現在帶頭向上攻
就說明著背後的需求
包括無塵室的產能
包括記憶體產能
傳統伺服器臺人基本上還在持續的稀缺
從臺灣伺服器代工廠
現在在整個第三季
年營收平均是成長130%
記憶體更不用講了
韓國記憶體出口平均年成長是412%
現在第五代和第四代的雙倍資料
記憶體現貨價格仍然在持續上漲當中
而且明顯高於合約價
所以短期的供應其實還是非常緊俏的
我們把整個標普500最為強勢的個股
今年年初以來到現在在報仇
即便當時疊得很慘的
在7月份的去槓桿
像Sandex
現在還是漲幅624%
莫德納是比較少數
在前幾名當中
非AI股的漲幅544%
戴爾漲了351%
美光276%
Intel 234%
Marvel 220%
希傑203%
超為196%
幾乎大部分清一色
這都是AI的硬體資料儲存或者晶片概念股
甚至從美光來看
當時在記憶體的股價去槓桿過程當中
的確獲得了蠻大的一個市場衝擊
不過現在的價格仍然守在1000塊美元之上
而且從上方來做觀察
其實也沒有什麼很具體的大量的籌碼區的賣壓
反而下方是有所支撐的
所以你說記憶體行情就正式的完全結束了嗎
從價格層面來看
套牢人似乎也不想像中來的多了
2027年現在我們當然知道
整個發債量還在持續提升
這也讓整個廢辦的本益比
目前下行速度是來的最為快速的
所以真正推動看第四季行情的
一方面當然是籌碼的原因
的確這一輪算洗的還蠻時間算久算乾淨的
第二就是接下來的企業買盤
還有本益比的誘因
是否會讓價值投資者開始陸續迴歸
那第三點當然就是高利率和低估值
是否能夠同時存在進一步拉高市場的行情
畢竟現在從高估值角度來看
你也不能說它是絕對高估值
但股價的確是相對昂貴一點
這是從體感上來說
所以高利率第一波影響的
我們如果撇開標普白指數
撇開費城半導體指數
撇開我們看到道瓊
撇開所有四大指數
我們就看高利率最為直接影響的
應該要從羅素2000
從中小型股來做第一波傳導
如果連羅素2000都能夠有效的撐住
那其實這個利率的問題
看起來就沒有想象中來得大了
現在小型股就有一點出現在那種
快要小嘎公的位置
因為羅素2000這一波跌幅算蠻重
從高點跌下來大概跌了10%左右
但關鍵是
它的長期趨勢線還是暫時守住的
而且重新站回到200日移動平均線之上
那現在唯一的好處就是
其實小型股情緒還算是蠻悲觀的
羅素2000在系統性的策略曝顯
大概只位於歷史的第7個百分位
超過9成時間持倉都比現在還來的高
這說明其實小型股在過去一段時間
是很明顯反映這種
殖利率走高之後的市場賣壓
那如果羅素2000現在能夠
重新的站穩開始往上攻
那說明最受到高利率影響的指數
看起來都能夠承受得住
目前的高利率
這就是生產力的有效提升
那回過看臺股也是如此
臺灣的硬體供應鏈
呈現的數字
因為臺股最近是創下歷史性高了
融資餘額已經連續
10個交易日增長
上市融資距離歷史高點
幾乎也算是創歷史性高了
上位融資已經創歷史性高了
所以總體市值衡量來看
槓桿程度沒有超過7月份高點
可是指數創高了
說明臺股本人的創高
也不是來自於市場的投機情緒
其實就是本益比緩步下滑之後
所造成的投資買盤
價值投資買盤的提升
就來自於基本面的拉昇
臺灣這一次我們看到
很像臺積電三奈米
五奈米的產能利用率
都已經超過了百分之百
AI的加速需求還是很強勁
有時候獲利提升不了
那也不是臺灣廠商的問題
訂單工廠都已經滿了
EPS能夠賺的有限
今年美股盈餘預估
平均會成長超過50%以上
這也使得現在臺股反而變成了
廢辦的領頭羊
優先創下歷史新高
而且臺股這一波的上漲
也不是由外資的全面追價所造成的
我們知道外資在今年每一戰事
還有今年夏季的去槓桿
曾經大幅的去賣出臺股
目前累積的部位
其實今年以來還是偏低
今年還是賣了1.3兆
可是臺股光靠自己就能夠有效的做
非常顯著拉伸
這說明內部資金的動能
還是能夠做比較顯著的
做吹捧的
這就是我們觀察到的宏觀跡象
當然回過頭來看
那到底是什麼原因
所以導致了就連羅素2000
最容易受到高利率衝擊的指數
就目前為止
它也能夠做有效提升
當然就要從這一次9月份的
非農就業數據來做觀察
這次非農就業數據
差的離譜
只有增長2.9萬人
這個是遠遠低於市場預期
就連8月份的新增非農
也從原本的16.2萬下修到13.3萬
這代表著搞不好10月份到時候公佈非農
又把9月份的2.9萬給下修了
每一次都校正迴歸
每一次都發現就業數據
比前一個月還要來得更慘
從7月份也從2.1萬下修到1萬人
兩個月合計比原本公佈的數字
少了接近有6萬個工作
代表著美國的企業招聘速度
比市場先前認知的更弱
那一個如此弱化的就業數據
怎麼會變成了股票市場的利多呢
因為升息預期至少在10月份消失了嘛
這麼差的就業數據
怎麼可能立即需要升息呢
所以現在市場上變成
壞消息就是好消息
好消息就是壞消息
但不管怎麼說
任何消息對於股市都是好消息
大概是這樣子
那比較弔詭的局面是什麼
就是家庭調查
它基本上是呈現了完全不同的畫面
從整個9月份的失業率來看
是從4.1%上行到4.2%
但是同一時間
勞動力人口增長了48.5萬個
來到1億7026萬人
就業人口反而開始做顯著增長
如果我們看兩套官方數據的一個追蹤
家庭調查基本上就是顯示
最近一個月大增了40.6萬人
但是企業調查就非農調查
只增長2.9萬人
這是兩個極端
家庭調查是直接問家庭有沒有工作
看起來還不錯
基本上沒有什麼升息預期消失的可能性
可是企業調查
他問的是這些企業家
你們最近有沒有招摸到新的員工
我們過去講過
市場上常常會因為下季度的
不管是在行政工作
文書工作
教育工作的一個輪替
或者加上在短期內通膨數據高升以後
也許會形成一些市場的消費形式變化
讓大家更為虛
願意做兼職
像我待會直播完
正常現在是在德國
以前在臺灣
我是直播完
馬上就要去送Uber Eats了
下午還有要去加油站打工
晚上還有超市
我一個人就貢獻四份非農了
你說這條就業市場非常好
所以就業市場
本來就要進行多重比較
從這兩項數據來看
一個是家庭調查
一個是企業調查
很明顯是有一個地方走錯了
有一點脫鉤的跡象
所以從9月份
對還有壽司店
有網友提醒
那是五份非農
所以從宏觀數據來做觀察
其實整個就業數據
它不能夠保證
目前就業市場有快速降溫的跡象
這是我個人的看法
從整個9月份平均時薪來看
這特別重要
它增長了0.1%
這個的確就是對於通膨降溫的訊號
但是就業是不是如想象中來的弱
這個值得商榷
因為0.1%
這就比市場預估的0.3低蠻多的
年征服也從3.1%降到了接近3%
所以從整體薪資通膨角度來看
的確壓力是沒這麼大了
另外一個是產業結構
也代表著工作越來越集中
醫療保健在9月份是增長了1.7萬人
但只有過去12個月
平均每個月增加大概3.3萬人
大約只有一半左右
門診醫療增長1.3萬人
醫院增長1.2萬人
所以你可以大概觀察得出來
那主要也是由一些醫療保健業來做支撐
其他領域
比如說保險業
減少了9萬人
零售業批發運輸
基本上增長幅度都是相對有限的
所以整個就業市場的概況
我們如果只用第一人稱來看
非農就業數據的話
確實很容易得到一個直覺
就是隻增長2.9萬人
薪資又降到年增幅3%以下
薪資和就業都擺在這裡
連總會不但沒有升息壓力
搞不好要降息了
這是一種角度
但是你把視角拉遠
我們上禮拜我有跟投資朋友分享
你用第三人稱來看
現在全球的資金概況
非農就業數據
就算它真的轉弱了
它無法解決目前的美債問題
為什麼
因為它背後包括油價的問題
食品的通膨外移效果
政府的赤字
全球軍費的暴增
AI企業的大量發債
日本資金的迴流
有日本在升息
貿易戰
供應鏈重組
聯總會的抗通膨態度
外國央行對於傳統美債的常債買盤
都在陸續退卻
這麼多宏觀原因
你可以靠非農就業數據的惡化
把殖利率硬是給拖下來嗎
其實難度是很高的
所以我覺得這邊真正值得省思的
不是說第一人稱
或者第三人稱
哪一個比較正確
你要有第一人稱的視角
來了解說
殖利率為什麼短期內可以下跌
為什麼市場突然歡呼
第三人稱
用宏觀思維來看
它是提醒我們把鏡頭拉遠
看那些單一數據
沒有解決的結構性問題
就算非農是對的
也不代表哲理律學會這樣子
因此快速下滑
所以不要把它當成一個
史詩級的歷讀
你應該背後想想看
可能更多是反映
AI的估值已經削減很多
買盤又後續跟上
因為這兩天剛好
那個啤酒節要結束了
那我就走在那慕尼黑街頭
經常看到地鐵裡面
不是就一群男生穿皮褲
女生就穿緊身的胸衣還有蒼裙
早上八九點就已經一堆人拿著巨大的啤酒杯
地鐵就拿著一瓶轉手去
到處都是嘔吐物
還有人睡在嘔吐物裡面
我印象最深刻的不是啤酒
是滿街都是這些穿著傳統服裝的年輕人
二三十歲的男生穿著這個叫做Lila Husson
就皮褲很緊的皮褲
女生是穿那個D&D
就是那個啤酒莊
那我就這樣搭地鐵逛街嘛
那我覺得很有趣就是
因為如果站在我
如果是以第三人稱的視角來看
我會覺得
那一個現代的年輕人
穿著一百年前的衣服
會有一種錯覺
就覺得這個服裝
感覺是上一輩的
你必須承認
因為我們常有一種錯覺
就覺得傳統文化
年輕人現代全球
可能參與度已經不是特別高了
臺灣其實也是這樣
臺灣國慶也快到了
那真的會一早去市政府升級的
年輕人也沒有幾個了
要升旗都在廁所升旗
所以如果你把鏡頭
切換到當地年輕人的第一視角
第一人稱
那事情就完全不同了
一個是第三視角
一個是第一視角
他們可能就不覺得自己在復古
他也不覺得自己在模仿上一代
對他們來講
這不是上一代的文化
這是我們的文化
這就讓我想到
有時候我們常常覺得
年輕人跟上一代已經脫節了
手機變了
工作變了
娛樂變了
生活方式也變了
可是很多底層的東西其實沒有消失
所以我們這邊講的就是
第一人稱第一視角和第三人稱第三視角的不同
有時候我們看每天的新聞
站在政府站在企業勞工或者消費者
投資人的第一人稱
和我們站在外面看整個數據的第三人稱
體感上就是不一樣
人均GDP今年就準備要挑戰五萬美元了
那你覺得這是第一視角還是第三視角呢
所以從我們不同的新聞來看
我們不只要看發生了什麼
我們更要去看
如果我們不是旁端者
我們是新聞裡面的那個人
我們看到的會是同一個世界嗎
這就是現在非農就業數據
和整個宏觀美在殖利率
利率預期升溫當中互相的角力
對我是沒有穿皮褲
但我有戴皮鞭
我們路徑隨俗
但我倒沒有特別喜歡喝酒
喝口水喝口水
之前老婆快生了
醫生就問老公
你以前有親身看過生產嗎
老公想了想
有啊
看過一次
醫生說
感覺怎麼樣呢
老公說
一開始四周非常的暗
突然之間就變得非常亮
所以你要搞清楚
你到底是用第三人稱來看世界
還是第一人稱
你不要人家問你第三人稱
你回第一人稱
人家問你賠產經驗
你回答的是出廠記憶
你還吟詩
初級俠
才通人
復行數十步
破然開朗
陶淵明
陶華雲記
所以第一人稱第三人稱
最值得思考的地方
就是我們身處其中的人
正在處於什麼樣的一個位階
整個系統正在發生什麼樣的改變
兩者不一定誰對誰錯
只是觀察的位置不同
這很重要
非農就業轉落
也不代表在軍問題就已經完全解決了
因為我覺得這一輪的殖利率上升
早就已經不是經濟太強
連準會不降息造成的
它是一系列的原因
從軍費
AI的企業債
到日本的資金迴流
貿易戰
聯準會
外國央行的買債
一系列因子
全部統合起來
才有這樣的第三視角
才是這樣的一個結果
喝口水
感覺今天有點累
8點50分
今天稍微聊一下美債之後
這個時候回過頭看
美國現在
包括政府財政的問題
壓力也是非常大的
從美國現在
在五年期的標數情況來看
其實就大概看得出來了
最近我們看到在五年級的標售
整體標售殖利率已經升高到5.033%
這不只是突破了5%
還創下了07年以來的最高
投標倍數更是降到18年以來的最低
隨後十年級殖利率當時也跟著一起衝高
可是都彰顯著
現在不管是長債還是短債
標售情況其實都沒有想象中還要來得好
如果往下看
等同於當短債預期也開始做有效推升以後
它就往下游端
來做真實的傳導了
下游端的直接傳導是什麼
其實就是房貸利率
我們看最近的美國30年期
房貸利率最近已經飆升到7.28%
這個一週內從7.03飆到7.28也算快了
這是2022年10月份以來的最大單週升幅
當然美國是固定利率
它沒有直接性的房貸衝擊
可是直接所形成的效果是
MBA的房貸申請量
正在以史詩驚人的速度下行
最近房貸申請量在9月最後一週
直接跌了6%
連續四周下滑
部分房眾已經心冷
現在全美的看房活動已經完全停止了
因為就算想買房
你也沒辦法負擔得起如此高的利率
所以美國的房市現在同時
第一就是面臨高房價
因為房價沒怎麼跌
第二是高利率
這種房貸利率無法做複印
或者說無法去順應未來幾十年的水準
第三就低供給
也沒有什麼人想要賣房子
為什麼
人家以前大量屋主
手上都是3% 4%的超低房貸
所以利率越高
那他們會願意換屋嗎
所以供給又減少
又讓房價難以下跌
這個就很尷尬的情況
其實跟臺灣有點像
就房價也沒跌多少
但利率已經慢慢在開始走升了
不過央行至少沒升息了
那供給的部分
現在市出的房源也不是特別多
這個就處於比較尷尬的情況
那往下做傳導
它所形成的效果是
可是美國國債的問題
至少在短期內沒有惡化
那有另外一個悄悄版
我們講說
這國債市場股市是這樣子
都會形成防禦性資產
和攻擊性資產的資金輪動
那在美國國債的部分
竟然在短期內
賣壓沒這麼大
那是不是海外市場也是如此呢
其實並非如此
我們看到
也許是由於歐債
尤其是法債市場的狙擊
所以導致了
美國公債相對賣壓沒這麼沉重
我們舉例來說
你像法國的部分
現在已經變成了
整個歐洲主權在新的市場壓力
現在從法國信用狀況來看
如果政府
如果無法在快速的兩年內
控制財政赤字
未來融資成本
可能會一路的失控
法國現在十年期的公債殖利率
大概已經從3.2%
一路上升到4.8%
在08年以來新高
最重要的事情不是上升
因為大家都在上升
是七大工業國當中
它是上升幅度來的最大的
現在法國10年期公債
相對於德國的公債殖利率
利差已經突破了1.2個百分點
所以它的問題就是
它不是特別嚴重
它是比其他國家嚴重的速度來得快
這已經是2012年
歐債危機以來的罕見水準
法國現在的借款成本
甚至比過去被視為
歐洲債務問題的意大利
還高出0.2個百分點
就法國的國債比意大利還便宜
那你覺得從這樣一個角度來看
市場上難道是認為法國經濟差得離譜嗎
當然不是如此
是法國的財政赤字壓力實在太大了
目前已經佔到GDP的5.5%
原本預估還可以壓在5%以內
目前政府明年已經預估要提出
削減540億歐元的支出方案
立即削減福利支出
來穩住目前的國債市場概況
不過按照這種速度的上行
我們再看看
這個是法國國債的CDS價格
已經全面超越了
當時15年16年
還有18年的水準
直接衝往當時在
12年13年的歐債危機
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
整個國債市場
即便非農稍微穩住了美債
歐洲市場壓力還是非常巨大的
我們也知道法國
這幾天新聞鬧得非常大
爆發大革命
學運幾乎已經全面失控了
一天就已經有1900人遭到逮捕
全國大概有1000所學校
222所遭到學生已經全面封鎖
那法國內政部也表示
上禮拜大概累積了抓了有接近4000人左右
那部分抗議已經演變成
縱火和街頭的衝突
那對內的部分
有這個學運的全面失控
那對外有國債的全面壓力
這我們就清楚知道
這個市場上對於法國的信用評級
當然會因此做適度的鬆動
現在法國總統大選
其實跟臺灣跟美國很像
大概只剩下7個月左右了
現在候選人多到15個
沒辦法確定說右派的Roppong
一定能夠當選
不過現在幾率是最高的
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
法國是否在未來一年到兩年
會有政策的極大轉彎
對於信用市場所造成的進一步壓力
這個是大家值得做進一步觀察的
你說德國國債是不是稍微好一點
是沒錯
可是德國內部的經濟情況
也沒有想象中來得好
我們從德國最新的工業數據來看
7月份雖然實質訂單
月增幅有2.5%
可是大部分都是政府擴大的國防支出
反而是德國最重要的汽車產業訂單
月減幅是1.7%
德國機械設備製造協會
現在從前7個月的實質產量來看
同期也下滑了4.1%
臺灣成長都是5成
南韓都是400%
然後德國最強的汽車業
還年減4.1%
你就可以完全瞭解
汽車已經完全是存量市場了
面對整個中國車廠的大規模崛起
德國預估在今年總裁員規模
已經來到接近5萬個行政值
那麼預估在整體明年的裁員情況底下
本輪事出至少會來到10萬人
現在像是福斯、BMW、賓士
都有陸續的裁員計劃
進行適度的資本準結措施
來嘗試的熬過本輪的汽車航空
當然你說英國現在脫歐以後
是否情況稍微好一點
因在大家也可以觀察到
這個形象其實也相當壓力來的大
最近甚至新首相博南
已經忘記是第幾個首相了
政府準備要重新檢討跟歐盟的關係
甚至他喊出不排除
重新全面加入歐盟
他認為現在英國脫歐已經弊大於利
目前考慮的方向除了維持現狀以外
也許可以重新考慮關稅同盟
加入歐洲的單一市場
恢復歐盟會員國的身份
這也是工廠現在
工黨現在立場重要的一個轉變
因為24年當時政綱
原本是明確排除要重新加入歐盟
現在是不排除
可能要重新加入到歐盟
這也說明了
他需要更多的市場
來支撐內部的經濟壓力
其實主要就是來自於
英國已經長期處於低成長
高支出還有高負債模式
政府支出佔國內生產毛額
大概已經來到45%
這個比例真的非常高
社會福利支出一年是3300億英鎊
人均實質國內生產毛額
大概是從19年的4.01萬英鎊
到現在才4.05萬
我們過去五年都已經接近翻倍了
它七年來幾乎在人均產出
沒有任何的成長
那當然了
現在不只是法國的學運正在爆發
英國內部也開始
越來越多的檢討聲浪
我們舉一個比較直觀的效果
英國現在在疫情之後
爆發最為顯著的衝擊
就是學生的消失潮
疫情前英格蘭大約每10名學生
有一名是處於長期缺席
就缺掉10%的課程
現在比例是每5人就有一人長期翹課
15年到26年
當時超過一半課程嚴重缺席的比例
差不多最多隻有10%左右
現在是50%
英國教育部的估算
長期缺席的學生到28歲以後
預估未來進入到監獄
吸毒自我傷害的風險
也在快速提高
那總體預估
按照英國教育部的公佈
大概是100萬年輕人
目前處於沒有就學
沒有工作
也沒有接受職業訓練的狀態
那預估未來的福利支出
還有產出損失
會超過1200億英鎊
這個就是在法國
在英國各地
所爆發的市場衝擊
所以這一系列的問題
所以導致歐洲債券
是否能夠有效的
受到市場承接
我感覺好像比美債
還更為嚴重
以前都覺得最嚴重的是日債
加上日債也還好
第二嚴重是美債
後來發現美債也還好穩住了
現在市場上開始聚焦到
歐洲債券的問題
法國是市場上最為擔憂的
好那不管怎麼說
整個2026年的大類資產的重新洗牌
商品價格還是漲幅第一名
有45%
那科技股續強
常債還是處於墊底的情況
不過在中間
我們看到幾大領域當中
基本上總體跌幅
跌最重的常債跌8%
然後其他像頭等債跌4.3%
黃金跌4.1%
其他跌幅大概0-2%還算正常
主要是股票市場
如果是持有大型部位的指數
包括從納斯達克100指數
現在漲幅兩成
小型股一成三
中型股11%
基本還是能夠讓今年績效
還保持的相對亮麗一點
所以我們今天主要是講
這個債券的觀察重點
對於金融市場的重力
就是利率往上
像政府的融資成本增加
企業發財變貴
房貸變貴
股票未來獲利的折現值
當然也會跟著提高
所以最後連AI公司的估值
和資本支出都會受到影響
可是我們要了解
投資真正要學到最後的
不是說單純每天多記幾個數字
我們要找到不同資產
背後的一個共同結構
今年就是商品大漲
然後科技股續強
然後長天期美債重挫
那三件不同的事情
它背後就是幾個結構
通膨,成長,AI,利率,資金成本
大概就是這樣子
你瞭解這樣結構以後
你就不需要死背每一個音符
你就瞭解主軸就是這邊
投資也是一樣
你不需要預測每一天的漲跌
你理解這首曲子
現在進行到哪一個段落
以及哪幾個底層變數
是正在決定它的節奏
就很重要了
這幾天我才從慕尼黑回奧地利
回一趟薩爾斯堡
就是去拜訪莫扎特的故居
走進莫扎特的城市
你很難把它想象成
因為他說天才型歌手
天才型作曲家
後來我跟著一個導遊團
講英文的
默默跟著沒付錢
聽到他講一個概念
他講說莫扎特的作品
你拆開來看
你會發現非常強烈的數學秩序
就對稱
莫扎特的旋律
你稍微聽一下
你大概可以瞭解
都是以兩小節
四小節
八小節
就相對於規整的單位組成的
一段旋律
先提出一個音樂上的問題
然後下一個再像回答一樣接回來
前面先建立張力
後面解決張力
也很像幾何圖形
那再來就比例
就本身它是大量建立在
二分四分八小節這些結構上
一個大段落裡面
它又可以切成更小的段落
那講的是什麼
就是其實後面在研究
莫扎德的作品當中
會很常看到這種大結構
包裝著小結構
很像數學裡面的階級和比例的關係
更有趣的排列組合
莫扎特以前不是最有名的一個例子
是他的音樂骰子游戲
就是作曲遊戲
他的玩法就是先準備很多小節的音樂
然後再透過指骰子的結果
去決定下一個小節要選哪一段
然後最後組合出一場完整的舞曲
大家竟然好開心
這個概念很有意思
音樂它是可以被拆成模組的
然後再用幾率和排列組合
重新的做拼裝
所以現在音樂到底好不好聽
其實背後跟數學有非常大的相關
如果頻率比例比較簡單
比如8度是2比1
那完全5度是3比2
人耳通常就會感受到
比較強烈的協和協調性
那現在人類其實很早就發現了
這種音樂跟數學的關係
從古希臘的畢達哥拉斯學派
大家都注意到
那個懸長跟音高之間的數學比例
後來克普勒加利略
都研究過音樂跟數學之間的關係
所以我要講什麼
我要講就是同構
就兩件看起來好像不同資產的漲幅
但底層大家的結構其實都是一樣
數學可以幫助我們理解音樂
反過來音樂也可以幫助我們理解
很多原本抽象的概念
所以我們現在看到的很多通膨
AI 利率 資金成本
它其實背後反映的都是同一套規則
這給投資朋友做一些思考
好 9.03分
喝口水
臺股上漲1071點
是在49547點
看起來
5萬點
是能夠提前達證
但是我們原本預估是每個月漲1萬點的
所以到年底至少要漲到12萬點
不是了
但是至少可以看得出來
臺股到底本輪的創高
真的是由於情緒的樂觀所堆高的嗎
還是背後是由獲利的基本面
來做顯著拉伸
這給投資品多做一些思考和留意
但不管怎麼看
現在牛市它不會因為漲太久而退休的
它會直到支撐它的音樂停止
支撐它的音樂背後是什麼
就是AI的資本支出
企業的獲利
資金的供給
當然現在值率率高一點
資金稍微緊繃一點
但就靠本益比的偏低
和基本面來做推升
是莫扎特說的
音樂家不會退休
直到心中沒有音樂才停止
Musicians don't retire
好像是那個勞伯丁尼洛講的
好像高年級實習生講的臺詞
不是手指有多快分貝就有多高
那是貝多芬說的
音樂家不會退休
直到心中沒有音樂才會停止
牛士不會因為長太多而退休
直到支撐他的音樂停止
喝口水喝口水
對耳邊的音樂響起了
原來是開盤的音樂
好臺股現在站穩了49500點左右
那我們今天主要跟投資朋友稍微梳理一下
從宏觀的在院市場的殖利率預期提升
到非農就業數據稍微沖銷
可是背後的因此其實都沒有瓦解
所以高利率的利空壓力仍然存在
那有利空壓力
那這些股市怎麼往上衝的呢
第一它本益比其實已經不算高了
那第二它的獲利還在持續的做拉伸
所以它是無耐性的上漲
不一定是吹捧式的
追漲式的上漲
在這樣的一個河流圖當中
跟今年五六月份的概況
本輪的創高
好像跟上半年又不太一樣了
也給投資朋友多做一些參考
如果喜歡我們的節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上八點半
早晨財經速解讀再相見
祝各位投資朋友看盤順利
炒盤愉快